let's go - lets go - Ernesto Ernesto has
called in before and is holding on
what's going on in esta oh wow you
remembered my name
we have what I didn't remember all right
so I have one proposal I want to know
your idea and that's a few things that
is their phone or Bluetooth because your
connection is important all right yeah I
cannot get it any better you think you
can get my answers and hang up on
arteries yeah okay go ahead what's it
what's your question Ernesto do you
think it worth it to try to fight word
for ideas are not in a political
spectrum like they're always on window
my idea is what if we tack the equation
what it means is we receive more people
but we said attacks for them for the
first five years we see how they behave
and if they do feather or if they
accomplish certain things we let them
save with Lois hat you know I love you
Ernesto but it's striking me as a little
bit dancing with an indentured servitude
type of things so that's that's I don't
think that that's for me no and as far
as you know the you can argue for things
that are outside of the Overton Window
but first you need to just expand the
Overton Window right so so step one
thats outside of the acceptable range of
debate that you think is a good idea
that's great we've just got a widened
the Overton Window first and then we can
have a more serious debate about it but
you know that the the pseudo indentured
servitude thing you're suggesting here I
don't I don't love I think it has some
ugly history attached to it you know or
Nesta let me pick up to one question
today just because I've got thirty
people holding in your connection now it
sounds like there's also I don't know if
your hand gliding
what but I'm gonna let you go it's very
windy where you are call back again okay
with question number two and you know
you've gotten on many times before so
it's not a not a huge deal